hey internet people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
today's october 12 2021 the world
continues to be completely insane and it
is my duty to clean it up thank you for
joining me as always don't forget to
share our videos subscribe to our
youtube channel tap the notification
bell
doesn't really do anything but we like
to give you some stuff to do while
you're watching uh we got a big show
today but before i get to any of that we
have a breaking situation right here in
the reuben report studio i got a text
message yesterday
from my producer michael now you guys
know i i sit in studio
with my producer michael sits over there
my director connor sits over there
michael's the one that sometimes during
the show if i need a fact check real
quick or i need some information or
something he's the one that i turned to
over there and he gives me a little
information he you know sets the order
of the show he's the one that i discuss
the the rundown with all that kind of
stuff i got a text from him yesterday
that he had the sniffles okay
he had a little bit of the sniffles
a little bit of uh sneezing
you know sniffles and sneezing basically
the same thing but you know these days
with science and everything i'm trying
to be as specific as possible so he had
the sniffles and he said dave maybe
tomorrow
i won't come in because of the sniffles
and i said you know what michael i
believe your medical choices are up to
you
uh but why don't we revisit it in the
morning and see what happens and we'll
talk about it and see where we're at and
i texted him this morning first thing in
the morning about 7 30 i said how you
feeling he said i've still got the
sniffles and then i had a choice
i had a choice as an employer now as an
employer in 2021 obviously you own all
of your employees like slaves and you're
allowed to tell them what they can and
can't do medically when they should be
injected with things and i could have
forced him i suppose to come in i should
have said to him go to the local
hospital get injected with some stuff
you know come here and sit here with the
sniffles i guess i could have done that
but
i'm a benevolent leader as you know and
michael is at home today so michael i
i'm sure you're watching hello there how
are you i hope you're having some
chicken soup hope you're feeling better
um but i mention all this just to point
out how really idiotic almost everything
we're dealing with right now is it's
like the guy's like 25 years old
perfectly healthy young person takes
care of himself and he's got the
sniffles and in the old days if you had
the sniffles you would just call into
work and say i can't come or you'd come
to work
and you know if you felt sick when
you're at work you'd leave but these
days we have now created a situation
where if anyone sneezes or coughs when's
the last time you heard someone cough in
public
you know what i mean like when you're on
a plane now and someone coughs it's like
you know where's the emergency exit we
better
suck them out the window like everyone
is becoming so
fearful of everything but i just want to
go on the record saying that i do not
own my employees they are free to make
whatever medical decisions uh they so
choose and you know if you're not
feeling well i know it's old school it's
old school to say to somebody if you're
not feeling well don't come to work and
michael you have sick days you're still
getting paid man you know it's all good
all good
but you know we'll see what happens
hopefully he hasn't uh you know he could
have infected the entire building where
he works
uh the entire building where he lives
and everybody the whole the whole city
could be going down so this could be the
last show anyway a lot of pressure on
connor over here con are you sniffling
today or anything no sniffles over there
i feel like a million bucks
all right so we got three stories for
you today we have to start with just
general covet nonsense because fauci you
know this fouchy guy we've talked about
him before have you heard about this
voucher guy he uh he goes on all the
sunday the weekend talk shows the
mainstream media talk shows that really
nobody's watching anymore but he just
spouts nonsense usually in complete
conflict with what he said the week
before so we've got a couple clips of
him i think two clips from the last
couple of days now we've got an old
school throwback of a fouchy and you're
not going to believe that he just it's
making up all of the [ __ ] that's
number one uh number two kyrie irving
nba player kyrie irving he plays for the
brooklyn nets as you guys know i don't
watch the nba anymore but he has now
been suspended by the nets because he
does not want to get vaccinated uh this
is this is quite extraordinary
considering he is a 29 year old at the
peak of physical fitness and health we
know that many other nba players uh are
also quite healthy and taking care of
themselves we don't know that there's
ever been a super spreader event at an
nba game from player to player despite
the fact they're sweating on each other
and bleeding on each other and crashing
into each other and you know all of the
stuff the germs flying all over the
place uh but the nets have decided to
suspend kyrie irving so we're going to
talk about that and then the counter to
that of course will be that greg abbott
who's the governor of texas has decided
that there will be no vaccine mandates
uh for companies that operate in texas
so there are little pockets of hope here
in america and our third story uh will
be all about
how the mainstream media has gone full
communist like they're not even playing
around anymore and you gotta kind of
admire it they were like we're democrats
you know we we're mainstream media
people but really we're democrats then
we're democratic socialists then we're
socialists and then they just
they just moved right over to communists
so we got a lot to do today again
michael feel better if you're not here
in studio tomorrow you're fired uh
before i talk about anything else i want
to tell you a little bit about bonner
private wine people i've got a bottle of
malbec right here you know if you enjoy
wine like i do and you're tired of
drinking the same boring bottles you
need to try the extreme altitude wine
that comes from the mountains of
argentina imagine at your next dinner
pouring a glass of red wine that comes
directly from the highest vineyards in
the entire world you guys may have seen
i had a dinner party of their night with
nikki haley and john voight kyle cashew
vlari elder we drank malbec any higher
and the grapes wouldn't even be able to
survive that because of that six
thousand to nine thousand feet what does
all this mean for the wine a flavor like
any wine you've ever tasted blackberry
leather smoking a little dark cherry
nature does all the work that means no
dyes and no flavor additives the small
family producers deep in the andes
mountains make a very limited quantity
just getting the wine bottles down from
the mountain unbroken is a challenge but
the guys over at
freethinkerwine.com have cracked the
code when it comes to getting these rare
wines to americans the best part they've
cut out the middleman you won't deal
with any big industry markup i'm
normally a cabernet guy but i really
enjoy pairing their malbecs with steak
it's like they were made for each other
visit freethinkerwine.com and you'll get
top quality extreme altitude wine for
about half the price my audience gets 50
off the line and 50 off shipping not bad
no need for a promo code just visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay let's talk about
this fouchy guy oh and i should tell you
so when we do the show normally
michael again who is sitting over there
has a computer and his computer has a
wire and the wire goes into the camera
that i'm looking at right now and that's
how i'm able to look at you guys the
entire time while i'm telling you all
the stories because he gives me like the
headline of the story thing the video
that i have to throw to etc today in an
incredible feat conor is running both
things he's directing and also running
it's incredible how you feeling over
there
you want the extra guac
extra guac for chipotle today for connor
all right very exciting uh but we've got
a couple things on the on the fouchy
front first off you know i did
uh this little unboxing the other day of
the fouchy box they sent us the fouchy
box disney had a big fouchy box and they
had candy in it and they had chocolate
in it and popcorn and a fouchy book and
like fouchy socks and god knows what
crap was in there well first off we gave
all of that crap away to our on locals
uh community so in the reuben report
locals community i just gave away some
fouchy crap i said i'd sign it and we
will do that and you're going to get
some fouchy crap if you want it we've
already given it away actually
but
the movie itself this documentary on
fauchi
their rotten tomatoes score came out and
take a look at this it has a 91
tomato meter score that's the score by
the quote-unquote critics so these are
the bloggers and the mainstream people
they love this thing 91
of them it's the greatest movie of all
time it makes the ten commandments look
like [ __ ]
audience score two percent
two percent of the people who watched
fauci
that were real people and not just you
know critic suck-ups to the power liked
it and actually the two percent if i'm
not mistaken has since been taken down
and now they're not even accepting any
more reviews from the people and it's
just such a perfect example of just like
the elite machine and the nonsense of
mainstream media and critics and
journalists and all these people they
say one thing but reality just does not
map to it at all well then fauci uh went
on cnn this weekend because he doesn't
spend much time in a lab you'd think
he'd be you know my god he's in charge
of the biggest pandemic of all time and
there's so many things to do and we've
got to splice dna and
i assume he has you know some sort of
very small binoculars that he looks on
things at and there's a whole thing with
science now right but he's always on tv
instead of being in the office being
over at the lab over there
and now he's
got some thoughts on covid and halloween
i think that particularly if you're
vaccinated but you can get out there
you're outdoors for the most part at
least when my children were out there
doing trick-or-treating
and enjoy it i mean this is a time that
children love it's it's a very important
part of the year for children i know my
children enjoyed it so i mean again
particularly if you're vaccinated if
you're not vaccinated again think about
it that you'll add an extra degree of
protection to yourself and your children
and your family and your community so
it's a good time to reflect on why it's
important to get vaccinated but go out
there and enjoy halloween as well as the
other holidays that will be coming up
yes yes halloween is a good time to
reflect on why it's important to get
vaccinated that's why halloween was
started actually about 200 years ago in
case you didn't know that it was all
about thinking about whether you should
be vaccinated or not um interestingly
halloween is basically the one day of
the year when uh before kovid that's the
day you were supposed to wear a mask now
he's kind of like i guess you could kind
of and if you're vaccinated you can kind
of do your thing it's not even that what
he said there was so ridiculous right
because he's basically saying if you're
vaccinated get out there of course he
never mentions anything about how
there's virtually no not none but
virtually no risk to
children.002 percent of kids have died
of covid under 500 cases according to
the cdc that's not to diminish any of
those lives and each one obviously is
very sad and it's it's actually
unimaginably horrific and you want to
prevent as much of that as possible but
you also have to figure out a way to go
about life remember when we had life and
we just lived it and went around and
knew that there was some risk and you
might catch the sniffles from your
producer michael like anything could
happen out there but he doesn't really
say it but basically you know should be
aware of things that are happening on
halloween and if you're vast you should
be out there i don't think many people
are listening to him at this point i
think people are going about holidays
thanksgiving and christmas and fourth of
july and halloween or whatever it might
be
and making the choices for themselves
which is how it should be
but then he was asked about people
indoors
uh and vaccinations this was also over
the weekend
how long do you think it will be until
it's safe for vaccinated people to once
again be indoors without a mask
you know i
it's always tough to predict that i
think if we continue to go down in the
cases that we're seeing right now and
more and more people get vaccinated as
the dynamics of the outbreak namely the
amount of virus circulating in the
community goes down i hope we'll be able
to pull back on some of those
restrictions
okay so i gave credit where credit was
due and i tried not to really go after
him in that previous segment right he's
kind of saying if you're vax on
halloween get out there whatever if
you're not take some precautions okay
here's where he becomes the the like
typical hypocritical liar that he is
notice he didn't give any numbers there
if we see the viral load go down it's
these amorphous statements they have
gone down something in california last
week there was something like 200 cases
of covid something like that and we've
still got all these people and masks and
all sorts of other stuff also he knows
it's like are you are you a anti-vaxxer
fouchy i'm confused you guys said if
everyone got vacs that the country would
go back to normal and everything else
now
you know this was back in like may or so
when the vax was really getting pushed
and they said you know we'll open up and
remember we had those two weeks in the
summer where things started getting back
to normal now he's basically saying
you shouldn't be indoors
if you're vaccinated so he must be an
anti-vaxxer or the vaccines are not
working as promised which again that's
what i got banned from twitter for
saying back in july
why would you not be allowed to be
indoors if you're vaccinated with other
vaccinated people are what level fauchy
give me numbers how about numbers not
just oh when it goes down enough because
he never says numbers because what
they're really doing is this really
what i would say is a really duplicitous
and dishonest and borderline evil game
of zero sum that oh we'll have to see
the numbers go down and down and down
what he's saying is until there's zero
otherwise we do have to keep some
restrictions
on you people and it's like if you think
for one second that anthony fauci is
wearing masks when he's indoors with
other people you're crazy there is
simply no way he does there was a video
yesterday of joe biden getting off a
helicopter with jill biden dr jill biden
and they had a uh
you know an assistant or somebody with
them and you can see them all wearing
masks as they're walking out of the
helicopter and then the assistant takes
her mask off and they keep walking well
now first off they obviously were not
wearing masks in the helicopter like
this is all
theater the the curtain has been pulled
back we've seen it guys we've seen the
wizard as i said last week
and
they're they're doing it right in front
of our eyes uh but now if you think this
is all just sort of like conflicting and
do halloween but don't be indoors if
you're vaccinated and everything else
listen to what uh fauci said about
vaccines a couple months ago
does the vaccine make you worse
and there are diseases in which you
vaccinate someone they get infected with
what you're trying to protect them with
and you actually enhance the infection
you can get a good feel for that in
animal models so that's going to be
interspersed at the same time that we're
testing we're going to try and make sure
we don't have enhancement so the worst
possible thing you could do is vaccinate
somebody to prevent infection and
actually make them work
that would be pretty bad if you
vaccinated someone to prevent infection
and then made it worse from what i
understand that might be from back in
october of last year so a year ago
so a year ago we were allowed to talk
about oh vaccines may not be perfect uh
these new types of vaccines actually
might make you more susceptible that
would be the worst possible thing notice
he would never say that now do you think
there's any chance in high hell that he
would get on one of these shows where
they give him these softball interviews
and be like you know actually it is
possible you know these vaccine
companies these big giant
pharmaceutical companies
they're not being held accountable
legally if they screw anything up and it
is possible that the vaccines either
aren't working as well as they should or
that maybe
it could make people even sicker or more
susceptible to disease etc etc i'm not
saying
that any of that is happening right now
i'm actually not what i'm saying is
that's what he said a year ago and we're
not allowed to talk about that idea
anymore so it's oh kind of go outside
for halloween
don't be inside if you're vaccinated
with other vaccinated people and yeah a
year ago i was saying that you know
vaccines could make you more susceptible
to a disease that's not at a that's not
like completely out of hand and that's
why we test things on animals and you
know we did sort of rush this thing out
but here we are
anyway i think you see my point today
people i don't like that guy very much
there you go uh all right let's move on
i want to talk to you guys about shamany
you know we've been telling you about
shamany uh for quite some time now
samantha from arcadia california is
raving about her remarkable results i
love genusell plants still
plant stem cell therapy i've used it all
over my face under my eyes it's cleared
up the flakiness even reduced my
forehead lines and someone even asked if
i got work done nope just geniuselle by
chamonix fine lines forehead wrinkles
dark spots bags puffiness under your
eyes gone right before your eyes and
best of all guaranteed results in as
little as 12 hours so you get your money
back it's that simple now get this
genusell has sold over a million
products that's a million products lots
of companies have tried to duplicate
them and they all fail it's for both men
and women i just mentioned in a recent
interview how i look back on my first
prageru video i was really stressed i
wasn't sleeping well i was
had a lot of stuff going on at the
moment i could see pretty huge bags
under my eyes but no more people all
across the country once they try
genusell products they fall in love and
they buy them again and again now you
can see the difference yourself today
get fifty percent off their most popular
packages go to love genusell.com dave
for fifty percent off these are all of
their customer favorites just go to love
g e n
c dot com slash dave for fifty percent
off order today all orders are upgraded
to free priority shipping from our
friends at love genusell and now back to
me okay so let's talk about kyrie irving
for just a moment as you know i don't
watch the nba anymore because it became
hyper politicized
i find the players mostly
to be sort of unbearable and constantly
talking about things that they don't
know what they're talking about and i
don't have a problem with anyone
doing that generally speaking but i
don't have to listen to it right and the
fact that espn and the major sports
networks have all become 24-hour
political pundit nonsense stuff so i
don't really watch them anymore however
i do know that kyrie irving is a member
of the new jersey nets and now he has
been suspended this has just happened in
the last uh two hours or so this is from
the new york post in the wake of net
star kyrie irving's apparent refusal to
get vaccinated against the against covet
19 the 29 year old will not be part of
the team until he does the nets
announced in a surprise statement
tuesday morning exactly one week before
the nets kick off their regular season
against the bucks the team announced
irving will not practice or play with
the team even during away games where he
is allowed to play due to local
restrictions in new york every nets and
knicks player must be vaccinated to
practice or play home games irving is
the only member of the nets who is not
vaccinated now let's just do like the
101 obvious stuff here to start first
off he's 29 years old first off kyrie
irving is healthier than you he's
healthier than me he is a young man at
the peak of physical fitness who i have
no doubt takes care of himself i don't
know all his positions on everything i
don't really care about all his
positions on everything he i as far as i
know he's not even anti-vaxxed in terms
of oh i don't want to be vaxxed ever or
i don't think anyone should ever have
axes i think he's talking about his own
medical choices which by the way a lot
of players i've actually talked to a
couple other players on the dl and a lot
of players are against this nonsense but
people don't want to put their
livelihoods and their jobs up on the
line and i think kyrie irving is about
to find out how evil the machine is
because when you step out against the
machine the machine crashes down on you
in horrific ways now kyrie irving has a
lot of money right this guy's i'm sure
he's got at least 20 million dollars in
the bank if he never wants to work again
he doesn't have to work again but he's
going to be called all sorts of horrible
things wait till the kyrie irving's
alt-right he's somehow a black white
supremacist much like larry elder who
spoke out against the machine if you
take a position counter to the narrative
that the mainstream monster wants you to
take you they will try to destroy you
but we need to support people like kyrie
irving it doesn't mean you're against
vaccines
if you want to get vaccinated get
vaccinated okay it doesn't mean that but
we need to stand up for the people who
are saying that i believe in my body my
choice i believe in individual autonomy
and not everyone can be brave enough to
do it this guy has the means to survive
for a little while doing it so if you
can't do it in your own life
maybe you could support him however you
can like you don't have to
quit your job or whatever it might be
everyone has to make choices for
themselves but like this guy deserves
our support right now this is this is
absolutely crazy and i would hearken you
back to my show you know two weeks ago
we had jonathan isaac that video from
jonathan isaac who's on the orlando
magic
basically saying the exact same thing
i had covered i'm healthy i don't
believe the government should be
mandating it people should make choices
what about natural antibodies
but and yet this will be framed i mean
just watch what the mainstream media
does to kyrie irving over the next
couple days the way they talk about him
that he's some radical right winger and
he's been brainwashed by alex jones and
just whatever crazy nonsense they can
throw at him they are going to throw at
him um as i tweeted out this morning you
know kyrie if you're watching this man
you know what you should do is just
leave the nba start a league with some
old players some retired guys maybe some
other players that don't want to get
vaccinated and start a league with other
people regular people that wish they
could have played basketball with guys
like you maybe it's half court you know
maybe it's full court it can be for men
and women it could be for tall people
and short people black and white gay and
straight vaccinated and unvaccinated
that would be more interesting we'll get
some celebrities to play we'll get just
regular guys who love hoops i'm not
kidding men and women like mix up
everything and let's get some league of
decent people how about we call it that
the basketball league for decent people
i don't watch the nba anymore but i
would probably watch something like that
i would try to play too i've got my
brace for my knee and i would like to
get out there and see what i could do so
kyrie that's my little advice to you uh
related to this story uh is actually a
little bit of hope so kyrie you know i
always talk to you guys about hope right
we just need hope you need to point to
people who are being brave you need to
point to someone maybe in the government
that's doing the right thing you need to
hear music that inspires you that like
sparks something in you to be hopeful
like that's what we need right now right
and there are little moments of it so
kyrie irving standing up for what he
believed in little bit of hope well now
there's some hope coming out of
texas because governor greg abbott today
issued an executive order stating that
no entity in texas can compel receipt of
a covid19 vaccination by any individual
including an employee or consumer who
objects to such vaccination for any
reason of personal conscience based on a
religious belief or for medical reasons
including prior recovery from covid19
the covet 19 vaccine is safe effective
and our best defense against the virus
but should remain voluntary and never
forced abbott said yes that's right
governor abbott and how refreshing it
must be for the people of texas to live
in a state not where the governor
chooses to be a king and demand that
everyone does the things he wants them
to do but where he says do what you want
do what's right for you get the vaccine
wear a mask don't do those things it's
up to you there's some risk involved and
there's risk either way we know all of
this stuff okay that's pretty good
that's opposed of course to our wannabe
uh king the tyrant gavin newsom here in
california uh who's demanding that it
you know it's gonna be all kids up from
five and up i think right now they're
doing 12 and up although his 12 year old
daughter apparently has not been
vaccinated yet
surprise surprise like the guy's the
biggest hypocrite on planet earth
and
this is just a very
obvious example of the of the split that
is happening in america whether we like
it or not states are going their own way
and making their own choices and where
you live
is going to be um
it's going to be more important to
choose where you live to be in line with
your views
because it's not going to be like the
country the states are going to be that
cohesive anymore that is just obvious
that is not a call for civil war it's
just a comment on the reality of the
situation
speaking of all of this uh the big
breaking news over the weekend was that
southwest airlines cancelled thousands
of flights over the weekend and of
course the mainstream media ran cover
the mainstream media started saying well
it was all weather related and there
were some weird things happening on the
ground but it was mostly weather related
although it was thousands of southwest
flights and it wasn't and it was a
couple other flights from united and
delta and american and a few others but
it was thousands of southwest and it's
like well wait a minute don't they all
have to deal with the same weather
something doesn't seem right well it
turned out
that hundreds if not thousands of
southwest employees were protesting
vaccine mandates and they didn't go to
work this is the only way we the people
have a chance to fight back now the
media doesn't want you to know that
which is why the media was saying this
was all about um weather you're not
going to see much of this obviously on
cnn and msnbc because they don't want
you to realize oh you know you're not
going to believe this you peon you
citizen you have the power to fight back
if you band together with other citizens
um so anyway so southwest had to cancel
all of these flights people were
obviously very upset but i saw a huge
amount of support for southwest like
it's not fun if you're trapped at an
airport but i saw tons and tons of
people supporting southwest employees
and being like you know basically i
tweeted this out i think this is the
right sentiment it's like southwest if
you want to like really like
like be the shining beacon right now you
could be like you know we're going to be
the one airline who does not have a
vaccine mandate we keep telling you guys
how safe planes are and everything else
and there's all the videos and they
spray all the planes they have that
green gun that looks like it's from
fortnight and they're spraying the
planes and they keep telling us how safe
plants are so we're not going to force
our employees we think most of them will
and they probably will and you guys can
do whatever you want when you're on the
planes they would have such a chance to
like get get literally millions of
people to be lifelong southwest airlines
uh fans right like customers right now
including me that's what they could do
they haven't done that yet however we've
got some video here from uh cnbc i
believe this is the ceo is it the ceo of
southwest uh talking a bit about the
mandates and what's going on with his
company what happened here with the
pilots
well yeah again i i think that uh we're
uniquely affected because we have so
many of our flights that touch florida
all the airlines were impacted on friday
it was just more of an impact on us and
it just took us longer to recover
but all of our employees worked very
hard through the weekend and
it's it's tough on our customers but
it's also tough on our people so
they did a phenomenal job there's
absolutely
no no issue in working with our
employees
talking about the vaccine mandate oh
yeah i mean there are some that have
very strong views on both sides of that
issue and you know it's not
as i think you probably know i've never
been uh in favor of corporations
imposing that kind of a mandate i'm not
in favor of that never have been
but the executive order from president
biden mandates that all federal
employees and then all federal
contractors which covers uh all the
major airlines
uh have to have a mandate and a vaccine
in place by december the 8th so we're
working through that
we're urging all of our employees to get
vaccinated
if they can't we're urging them to seek
an accommodation either for medical or
religious reasons
and but my goal obviously is that no one
loses their job
the the objective here obviously is to
improve health and safety
not for people to lose their jobs so
yes we have some very strong
views on that topic but that that's not
what uh was at issue with southwest uh
over the weekend
okay that's greg kelly he is the ceo of
southwest airlines that's a pretty
decent guy right there that's a guy
that's trying to run a company that's a
guy who's saying i don't want the
government telling me what to do i'm
trying to respect my employees beliefs i
have my own personal beliefs and we're
trying to do the best that we can you
know he sort of hedged his bets at the
beginning where he kind of implied he
didn't fully say it that it had
something to do with south west florida
weather all these delays except again
many airlines fly through southwest
florida so the idea that you know over a
thousand flights were delayed uh on
southwest that it only affected them is
sort of silly weather related but he's
trying not to throw anybody on the bus
because then he's also showing a lot of
sympathy for his employees that are
saying we don't want these vaccine
mandates and he himself is saying that
he does not want to be forced into doing
it now it's important that i say this
because there is a lot of confusion
around this and i just spoke to harmy
dylan who is a fantastic civil rights
lawyer because i wanted to clarify
what's going on here there is a federal
executive order that biden put out it
was probably about six weeks ago now
about federal workers and federal
contractors so if you are a federal
worker for the united states government
there is an executive order saying that
you have to be uh
vaccinated i'm not for that but that's
what the order says and then it went
further it said that if you're a federal
contractor you have to be as well your
employees have to be as well that means
if you're just some company that does
some random business
with the government you make signs for
them you paint some something on the
street you sell them you know key chains
your employees have to be vaccinated too
now that seems like complete nonsense to
me uh but that's where we're at on the
executive order the thing that needs to
be clarified and everybody really needs
to understand this and we're going to
link to an article from the federalist
down below that sean davis passed over
to me right before we started is there
is no executive order
on forcing companies with more than 100
employees to vaccinate all of their
employees it does not exist there was a
press release about it but there is no
executive order so there was a lot of
confusion around this because every
there's there's
literally there's got to be hundreds of
thousands of companies in the united
states that over have over 100 employees
and i think a ton of them thought oh my
god we're going to have to force our
employees to do this otherwise we're
going to get these crazy
fines and such it does not exist now
they may try to push it through and i
think
there was video of jen saki a couple
weeks ago being deliberately confusing
about it to scare people because this
administration is all about fear and
keeping the people in fear but it simply
does not exist yet there is some sort of
guidance and a press release again we've
got an article from the federalist in
the description down below so you can
take a look at it
but anyway i absolutely stand with the
people of southwest airlines the
employees i stand with the employees of
american airlines i stand with i stand
with anyone that's trying to maintain a
little bit of control over their own
life right now as it's being taken away
as we are watching this is the slow
march
of socialism marxism communism it really
is here that's not like some crazy
alarmist thing that i am trying to say
but this is how it happens a country
doesn't become communist overnight you
don't just wake up the next day and
you're communist or fascist but we are
watching an out of control federal
government run by a man who clearly is
not cognitively able to run it and i
don't even think he's running it in the
first place we are watching the march on
all free
people and what are you gonna do about
it that's the question and of course
moving on to our third segment all of
this this this march towards communism
is being fueled
by our mainstream media if you don't
believe me we've got about a two-minute
uh compilation video from grabian media
of uh the lefties
and the media cohorts uh pushing
communism enjoy
no one likes
to mandate people to do things that they
may not want to do
but sometimes for the greater good of
society
you have to do that you got to start
telling people if you don't get
vaccinated you can't come into this
office or this place of business we
really need to make it clear that there
are privileges associated with being an
american that if you wish to have these
privileges you need to get vaccinated
travel and having the right to travel
interstate it's not a constitutional
right as far as i'm as far as i know
getting vaccinated is not a personal
choice it's not it's something that we
do for the community i think that he
should approach this with an iron fist
if you don't get vaccinated you can't
come to work people aren't then going to
threaten to go to another workplace if
every workplace has that same
requirement that's a good thing so i
don't think it's overreach i think this
is what's needed in the middle of a
pandemic and in fact i think the binding
administration if anything could have
gone even further and those governors
that stand in the way i think it was
very clear from the president's tone
today
that uh he will run over them if you
don't get vaccinated you can't come into
this gym screw your freedom because with
freedom comes applications and uh and
had responsibilities your personal
choice ends where my right not to get
killed by an infectious disease begins
so we have these collective actions for
the good of the community not the
individual we don't live in a bubble we
live in a community
and that is why there have been a number
of instances throughout history where we
have made a decision as a society to
abide by common rules that protect the
common good we really have to you know
think in terms of what is best for
society at this point if you don't get
vaccinated you can't come into this get
onto this airplane you can stay
unvaccinated if you want but you're not
going to be able to travel to see your
family we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
there you have it the tolerant and
diverse and open and freedom-loving and
honest and decent
lefty media and politicians as you were
watching that how did you feel i mean
really feel like as you were watching
i've now watched it probably 10 times
today um but even on this showing just
now it's like man you feel kind of tense
right it's like there are really really
bad people out there right now pushing
really really bad ideas
and the irony of course the ultimate
irony is if donald trump was president
and donald trump was pushing a federal
vaccine mandate across the entire
country every single one of those lying
sellout buffoons would be saying the
exact same reverse thing not the same
thing they would be saying the complete
reverse thing they would be saying this
is overreach
he's a maniac this is fascism this is
biomedical tyranny they would all be
saying that but they like biden and they
like the power and they like the machine
and scratch a progressive and find a
really hysterical authoritarian okay
that it is just so obvious and arnold
schwarzenegger what do you say screw
your freedom is that what he said screw
your freedom arnold schwarzenegger the
terminator commando
dennis quaid from total recall
like what
god these people what do we do what do
we do as as free decent people like like
just think of the difference of of the
type of people that now exist in the
world i would say you know we can talk
about left right we can talk about
top bottom we can talk about uh you know
conservative liberal we could talk about
all of those things but it's basically
like you've got some people
who want to understand the world and
some people who want to control the
world that's what this has all boiled
down to now and it's becoming
very very obvious to any of us that are
paying attention i don't have all the
answers but i don't think they have all
the answers either so what i want to do
is create a ground that the most freedom
can exist so that we can all make the
choices for ourself that we feel is
right and within that there's going to
be some messiness but you know what
comes with that messiness the
opportunity for human flourishing that's
a freaking beautiful thing that's what
this country was based upon
those people the people that demand you
bow to them the people that you demand
that demand that you not talk about
certain things the people who would
gladly have you fired and silenced and
pushed to the margins of society it's
like they're not the good guys and until
enough of us are willing to say that and
enough of us are willing to say boy it's
getting hot in this pot right now it's
getting pretty hot
you know we better do something before
we all boil it's like they're going to
keep moving they're just going to keep
moving so we have
our work cut out for us as i often say
uh guys if you didn't see it yesterday
we didn't have a regular show uh i
interviewed michael knowles all about
christopher columbus it was christopher
columbus day yesterday columbus day and
i don't think joe biden tweeted about it
he did tweet about indigenous people's
day
but you know columbus kind of did
discover the whole thing and was a
pretty decent guy with a bit of a
checkered history like all people
including you and including me
and uh we should be honoring him and i
still call it columbus day because i'm
old school so you can watch my interview
with michael knowles also my interview
my full interview with blake masters
who's running for
senate in arizona wrote zero to run
which is right over my shoulder with
peter thiel that's up right now and part
parts one and two of my interview with
michael shellenberg a really interesting
guy he was a lefty lefty lefty
progressive and then he started
swallowing the red pills uh and he just
wrote about a book called san francisco
it's basically about how progressives
destroy cities we had a really
fascinating interview uh on his own
political evolution and just why
progressives are so bad at everything
everything that they touch turns to [ __ ]
i should have wrote the blurb on the
book uh join me at
reubenreport.locals.com for food
pictures and wine and all sorts of other
fun stuff and by the way i think i've
mentioned this a couple times but we now
do a live chat we we do not do live chat
on youtube during the show because it's
just filled with trolls and bots and
haters obviously you guys can comment
once we post the show
afterwards but we do do a live
completely uncensored chat during the
show which you can do on your phone or
desktop at
reubenreport.locals.com and some of my
team members are in there and uh and
helen my assistant who is guiding the
conversation she can get messages to me
during the show so i can give you guys
shout outs and answer specific questions
and you can correct me if i screwed
something up imagine them doing that on
cnn if they had the fans actually
correcting them in real time that would
be something else uh all right
it's tuesday i enjoyed the show today i
hope you did too have a great day see
you tomorrow and michael
get that injection and you're fired
goodbye